[Musique]
jeudi 1er février bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur TV 78 voici les titres de
l'actualité se dirig--on vers la fin du
mouvement les syndicats majoritaires des
agriculteurs Appell ce soir à suspendre
les blocages après une semaine de
mobilisation et ce après les annonces du
jour du premier ministre Gabriel Attal
dans les ielines les agriculteurs sont
toujours en place sur la 13 et la 10
certains d'entre eux ont même bloqué la
National 12 aujourd'hui dans les deux
cens de circulation entre mé et le
tunnel de
chenévière un étudiant sur 5 ne
mangerait pas à sa fin selon la
Fédération des associations générales
étudiantes pour faire face à cette
hausse de la précarité les initiatives
solidaires se multiplient exemple dans
cette édition à l'université Versailles
5 an en Yveline où plusieurs
distributions alimentaires sont
organisées dans l'année
depuis samedi dernier la ville de
rambouill sa nouvelle ambassadrice
Andrian Nina Adria Mino arinozi a été
élu reine du Muga 2024 au terme d'une
soirée de gala à la salle Pat nôre elle
est jeune femme de 22 ans représentant
l'association des commerçants de la
ville l' emporté face à six autres
candidates elle perpétue une longue
tradition dans le sud yelin lancé depuis
1911 et puis ce concours arrive bientôt
à son terme la finale du tremplin des
voix porté par l'association la voix en
scène est au programme ce samedi c'est à
la Maison de l'Environnement de Manil
etamoau sur scène 20 artistes répartis
dans trois catégories qui vont tenter de
remporter cette 9e saison on en parle
dans les invité du 78 en 2uxè partie
d'émission sans oublier notre sélection
des idées de sortie à faire ce weekend
dans les zblin et c'est avec vous
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir de la rédaction
de tv78 comme tous les jeudis vous venez
nous présenter cette sélection quel est
le menu du jour je vous parlerai
notamment ce soir grégoryi du festival
Ciné junior qui se tient ce weekend
encore à maniléamo je sais pas si vous
aimez chanter à vos perdu je vous
parlerai également d'un karaoké en live
sans band de son mais avec des musiciens
c'est intéressant donc ça ce sera tout à
l'heure dans le 78 mais d'abord on va
faire le point avec vous sur les
actualités du jour dans les
evvlines déjà un point de situation sur
les agriculteurs ça évolue ce soir oui
alors ce matin encore la 13 et la 10
était inaccessible un cortège de
tracteurs s'est déplacé en fin de
matinée sur la National 12 au niveau de
mé les agriculteurs ont bloqué les deux
cens de circulation province- Paris et
parisprovince vous avez suivi dans la
journée le Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal a prononcé un discours en début
d'après-midi il a annoncé plusieurs
mesures pour répondre aux exploitants
agricoles notamment un soutien fiscal et
social de 150 millions d'euros pour les
éleveurs l'arrêt des importations de
fruits et légumes cultivés avec le
pesticide ccllopride pour éviter la
concurrence déloyal ou une augmentation
massif de contrôle des industriels et
des supermarchés la FDSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs appellent toujours pardon
Appell à suspendre tous les blocages
mais àpone la situation reste pour le
moment inchangé la route est toujours
bloquée au moment où je vous parle on
suis bien sûr cette situation avec
attention alors la colère aussi gronderé
du côté des enseignants aujourd'hui oui
les professeurs de maternelle du
primaire et du secondaire se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui avec ce
rassemblement lancé par les syndicats il
voudrait obtenir une augmentation
salariale de meilleures conditions de
travail et dénonce le manque de moyens
et de remplacement il protestait
également contre la réforme du choc des
savoirs instauré par Gabriel hatal
ancien ministre de l'Éducation et actuel
Premier ministre dès la rentrée 2024 il
prévoit la création de groupe de niveau
en mathématique et en français pour les
élèves du 6e et du 5e pour le personnel
enseignant cette réforme risque d'avoir
de graves conséquences au collège
Alexandre Duma à morpa aujourd'hui 80 %
des enseignants étaient mobilisé selon
le syndicat départemental SNES on écoute
les propos recueillis au micro de Clara
de Frutos
idéologiquement on y est pas du tout
pour nous l'école elle sert pas à trier
socialement les élèves elle est là pour
permettre à tous les élèves de réussir
dans de bonnes conditions on n pas de
texte réglementaire on n pas de décret
donc on doit appliquer une réforme sans
s'appuyer sur ni des moyens ni des
textes donc on est complètement
désemparé c'est une catastrophe pour
nous sans ensuite les dégradations de
conditions de travail que ça entraîne en
cascade suite à cette réforme on va
devoir faire des alignements
pédagogique une progression commune
mathématique une progression commune en
français ce qui va nous restreindre
notre pédagogie et notre liberté
pédagogique à force de cût de nouvelles
réformes à force de décret les
professeurs sont fatigués épuisés et ont
commence à en avoir marre de tout ça et
des parents d'élèves aussi étaient
présents ce matin pour soutenir les
professeur en grève on est là de toute
façon pour les enseignants qui sont de
qualité et pour surtout nos enfants quel
est l'avenir de nos enfants en fait qui
vont arriver là dans dans les dans les
prochaines années finalement donc c'est
aussi surtout pour ça qu'on est là
aujourd'hui et des chiffres qui nous
sont parvenus il y a peu par l'académie
de Versailles sur la mobilisation des
enseignants aujourd'hui selon l'académie
de Versailles 35 % des enseignants
étaient mobilisés dans les collèges un
peu plus de 13 % chez les enseignants
des lycées gén et technologique et
environ 18 % un peu moins même de 19 %
chez les professeurs de primaire autre
actualité Gabriel c'était il y a 70 ans
l'abbé Pierre lançait un appel oui un
appel à l'aide on peut même dire
prononcé il y a 70 ans vous l'avez dit
et qui résonne toujours aujourd'hui le
voici mes amis au secours une femme
vient de mourir gelée cette nuit à 3h
sur le trottoir du boulevard Sébastopol
ce message d'indignation reste encore
d'actualité en 2023 ce sont 330000
personnes qui dorment dans la rue contre
143000 en 2012 en France selon le
rapport de la fondation abépierre de
2024 à cette occasion le centre Emmaus
de Bougival organise du 1er au 3 février
des expositions et des projections pour
partager l'histoire de l'homme d'église
qui était la baépierre une information
qui va intéresser les jeunes qui
s'interrogent sur leur avenir comme
chaque année gu encs aide les étudiants
dans leur orientation oui le forum de la
voie professionnelle ouvrira ses portes
demain des 9h jusqu'à 19h au Pavillon
Pierre valdec Rousseau un large choix de
métier et de formation sera représenté
don le secteur du bâtiment de la santé
de la défense du transport ou encore de
l'hôtellerie ce forum il s'adresse
particulièrement aux collégiens qui
souhaitent se diriger vers une finière
professionnelle et vous terminez ces
informations du jour avec une web-série
oui Grégory elle s'appelle démo c'est le
nom de cette série mais c'est aussi
l'abréviation du dispositif d'éducation
mus musicale et orchestrale à vocation
sociale c'est un projet qui mêle social
et démocratisation culturelle 90 enfants
qui habitent sur le territoire
cinquantinois dans des quartiers qui qui
relèvent de la politique de la ville
sont concernés leur aventure a commencé
en 2022 lorsqu'ils ont rejoint
l'orchestre elle se terminera en 2025
avec le concert de fin de cycle alors la
websérie vous permet de suivre leur
progression et leur évolution deux
épisodes sont déjà en ligne sur la
chaîne Youtube de 5S en Yveline merci
Gabriel et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les ivelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news plusieurs fois dans l'année les
associations étudiantes de l'Université
Versailles saintquenttin en yeline se
mobilisent pour venir en aide au plus
précaire un étudiant sur C ne mangerait
pas à sa fin selon une étude récente de
la FAGE la Fédération des associations
générales étudiantes et parmi les les
actions mises en place des distributions
alimentaires justement Gabrielle Gontier
vous en avez suivi une l'une de ces
distributions sur le campus de guyancour
pâtes pain conservve et même produits de
première nécessité depuis quelques
années les distributions alimentaires
sont régulières à l'université de
versaill 50 ans en Yveline on a pas mal
de conserves et de soupe de sauce en
Boco et les produits d'hygiène ça aussi
les étudiant ils prennent tous les
produits d'hygiène autant que possible
même les trucs aussi basiques le savon
le dentifrice beaucoup aussi tampon les
serviettes euh toutes les étudiantes qui
passent prennent au moins un produit
menstruel donc ça montre qu'il y a
réellement un besoin et une nécessité
des distributions d'autant plus
nécessaires que d'après l'UNEF principal
syndicat étudiant le coût de la vie
étudiante a augmenté de plus de 6 % pour
l'année universitaire
2023-2024 au niveau national aujourd'hui
c'est un/ers des étudiants qui ont faim
on sent juste un désintérêt envers la
jeunesse c'est-à-dire que là avant la la
le département des ielines payit l'euro
restant des repas à 1 € pour les
étudiants boursiers et là c'est la fin
la situation elle est extrêmement
alarmante et on le ressent dans le
nombre de personnes qui viennent
assister à ces distributions
alimentaires des distributions qui
représent parfois un véritable
soulagement pour ses étudiants une fois
que tu as payé toutes tes charges et tes
factures et cetera il te reste très peu
pour te faire plaisir ou même des fois
pour manger donc faut faire des choix
donc quand il y a des il y a des
occasions comme ça faut faut les saisir
c'est arrangeant pour les produits de
première nécessité qu'on peut pas
forcément s'acheter ou qu'on doit un peu
se saigner pour acheter pendant les 3
heures de distribution une centaine
d'étudiants ont pu bénéficier des dons
une situation alarmante dont a
conscience le président de l'université
ça toujours été un sujet majeur pour
pour notre université la précarité
étudiante et évidemment la période du
covid a été un fort révélateur on a mis
tous les moyens nécessaires au-delà des
moyens que nous offrait l'état
l'université a été l'acteur principal
pour soutenir aider les étudiants et je
suis très heureux de voir que les
associations étudiantes ou les
organisations étudiantes aussi sont
acteurs une solidarité qui va au-delà
des mur de l'université puisque
l'intégralité des denrées distribuées
font l'objet de Don
extérieur créer du lien social autour de
la musique c'est le combat que mène
unissons depuis 2019 cette association
récupère et installe des pianos dans des
écoles des épades et des prisons ils y
sont en libre service une manière de
casser l'image parfois élitiste du piano
le reportage de Julien
Leroi une page de 30 ans entre Caroline
et son piano se tourne cette habitante
de Ben a décidé de faire don de son
instrument à l'association unisson basée
à trappe elle ass sur le lien entre des
particuliers ou des entreprises
souhaitant se séparer de leur piano pour
les offrir à des lieux collectifs non
commerciaux un objet parfois chargé
d'histoire dont certains donateurs ont
du mal à se
séparer il va me manquer
mais c'est toujours mieux qu'il soit
utilisé il va être utilisé par des
jeunes dans une collectivité pas très
loin de chez nous donc c'est pour nous
c'était la la meilleure option plutôt
que de le garder ici
inutilisé arrivé dans son nouveau foyer
le 62e don d'unisson prend place dans le
hall du collège François rabelet à Ben
tous les élèves pourront jouer en libre
service au moment des récréations quel
que soit leur niveau le principal avait
remarqué les bienfaits de cette
instrument dans un autre établissement
scolaire ça apporte à la fois de la
gaieté de la sérénité et des temps de
calme parce que les élèves se regroupent
autour du piano et il y avait beaucoup
moins de dispersion des mouvements les
élèves étaient assez attentif à leurs
camarades qui jouaient du piano et
restaient autour
d'eux rien que dans le collège je suis
sûre qu'il y a plein de pianistes que je
connais pas et que je pourrais peut-être
discuter avec eux si je les vois J jou
et tout on pourrait échanger notre
savoir et puis pourquoi pas jouer
ensemble un amour du piano pour
Sébastien peronau l'histoire commence en
2019 avec une amie il fonde unisson avec
la volonté de casser l'image élitiste de
cette objet pour l'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre la musique qui est incarnée par
cet instrument qui est le piano est
justement un moyen de de se rassembler
de voilà il y a il peut y avoir à la
fois un petit côté poétique sur certains
morceaux mais aussi un caractère festif
sur d'autres et c'est un peu aussi la
pluralité de cet instrument qui qui fait
sa force hôpitaux maisons de retraite ou
prison des lieux d'accueil parfois
atypiques pour recevoir les précieux
pianos de Sébastien une façon de faire
raisonner les notes pour rendre plus
chaleureux les couloirs de ces
[Musique]
lieux et je vous propose de sortir dans
les evvelines pour la suite du
avec votre sélection Gabriel Gontier
comme chaque jeudi on débute avec un
rendez-vous à Manil etamoau et oui
Grégory je vous en parlais jusqu'au 6
février la commune accueille le festival
Ciné junior 2024 la thématique qui a été
choisie pour cette 34e édition c'est
celle du voyage et cette année encore le
festival est organisé par l'association
cinéma public l'objectif de l'événement
permettre aux enfants et aux adolescents
de découvrir des films français et
étrangers de qualité ce samedi c'est le
courtmétrage un voyage en bonne
compagnie qui sera proposé aux
spectateurs on parlera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure de manilamo avec un événement
musical le tremplin des voix la finale a
lieu ce weekend justement de musique il
en est question de votre dans votre
prochaine idée avec du caraaok en live
oui et petite spécificité pour ce
karaaoke vous allez pouvoir chanter non
pas sur une bande son mais en live avec
des musiciens expérimentés une
expérience originale et surtout un
véritable spectacle à partager en
famille ou entre amis alors rendez-vous
Grégory si vous êtes intéressé vendredi
des 19h30 au scarabé de la verrière
c'est bien noté autre rendez-vous festif
avec l'événement festigieux qui fait son
grand retour ce weekend oui jeu de
plateau jeu de rôle chute de Domino et
même gaming la 9e édition du festigieux
fait son retour ce weekend à Villepreux
l'événement est organisé par deux
associations villepreusienne la croisée
des mondes et le tourbillon l'objectif
présenter les nouveautés 2024 avec un
accent particulier mis sur la thématique
sportive en cette année olympique un
événement pour toute la famille en
attendant le retour des beaux jours vous
nous proposez une sortie prendre pour
prendre l'air une sortie en forêt oui
une balade nature dans la forêt vous
l'avez dit c'est ce que vous proposent
des élèves de l'école du savoirvert le
centre horticole du Tremblet sur mold au
travers d'une balade ils vous feront
découvrir certains sites remarquables de
la forêt qui abrite une biodiversité
importante la visite elle sera suivie
d'une collation à noter que le tarif de
cette visite est à votre convenance et
que les bénéfices seront reversés à
l'association access sour 78 une sortie
donc solidaire pour redécouvrir notre
territoire on termine avec une idée
quelque peu insolite oui insolite c'est
le mot je vous propose une visite guidée
un peu originale que dirieez-vous
d'embarquer à bord du tram T13 pour une
visite commentée c'est ce que propose
l'office du tourisme Saint-Germain
boucle de scène installé à bord du train
un guide vous présentera l'histoire du
rail depuis l'arrivée de la première
ligne trans ortant des voyageurs en 1847
à Saint-Germain en lait jusqu'à
l'inauguration du T13 en 2022 une façon
de redécouvrir l'histoire et le
patrimoine depuis cette nouvelle ligne
merci Gabriel pour votre sélection une
petite préférence ah le karaoke ça peut
être sympa quand même je suis d'accord
avec vous aussi le le kqueet c'est c'est
mon choix en tout cas l'ambiance était
au rendez-vous samedi dernier à
Rambouillet puisqu'il y avait cette
élection de la ren du muguet adrianina
Andrianina andriamino arinozi a été élu
reen du muget g 2024 à l'issue d'une
soirée de gala la jeune femme de 22 ans
va donc représenter la jeunesse
rambolitaine et ce pendant un an retour
en image sur son sacre avec Julien
Leroi arrivé enfantfare pour les
candidates depuis 1911 la commune de
Rambouillet ne Déroche pas à sa
traditionnelle Nuit du muguet pour cette
édition 2024 C prétendantes sont en
liste pour devenir reine ici pas de
critère physique qui met l'importance de
transmettre des valeurs de solidarité à
travers une association de la commune
chacune d'entre elles représente
finalement ce qu'est le bénévolat la
convivialité le rassemblement des
personnes entre elles c'est aussi et
bien les valeurs de la jeunesse qui
supporte la ville de Rambouillet je suis
totalement stressée ça pas ça se voit
pas bon j'espère je suis totalement
stressé je sais pas quoi dire aux aut
tables mais on espère juste que que tout
se passe bien et puis que la meilleur
gagne comme pour un concours de beauté
classique chaque candidate doit savoir
se présenter en public une salle remplie
d'environ 450 personnes qu'il faut
convaincre de voter pour elle Andria
Nina 22 ans chanteuse et musicienne
représente l'association des commerçants
de Rambouillet elle se définit comme une
personne organisée désireuse de se
mettre au service de la jeunesse de la
commune j'ai grandi ici et et voilà ça
ça fait partie de moi et et
pouvoirésenter cette ville et en être
fier avec l'association qui me qui qui m
à cœur aussi c'est important vous mettez
par par numéro ou
ou le moment du dépouillement une étape
solennelle pour ce concours les
bulletins de la salle sont ajoutés au
vote de la presse local et d'Internet
soit près de 6000 voix et la reine duug
représente l'association des commerçants
et Artis
des
Andrié nina est élu 96e reine du muguet
ce samedi 27 janvier elle succède à
Jessica Gomez gagnante de l'édition 2023
elle sera accompagnée par ses deux
dauphines méina Zay Germain et
emmaagirie je suis vraiment très
surprise ça me fait vraiment très
plaisir et c'est surtout de la joie je
suis vraiment très heureuse prochain
rendez-vous pour la nouvelle reine son
couronnement il y aura lieu à rbouiller
en mai prochain lors des festivités de
la fête du muguet
24 bravo à la nouvelle reine du muguet
ainsi qu'à ses Dauphine méina et Emma
aussi à toutes les autres candidates
juste avant de passer aux invités du 78
on va jeter un petit coup d'œil aux
prévisions météo de
demain demain matin la brume la brume
gagnera le territoire yvelinois compté 3
degrés dans les secteurs de Versailles
et manentelajolie 2 degr à Oudan et
Rambouillet l'après-midi le ciel restera
sombre dans le car nord-ouest des
Yvelines vous pourrez profiter peut-être
de quelques éclaircis autour de
Versailles et Rambouillet il fera en
moyenne de 10 à 11°gr ce weekend le
temps sera plutôt mossade pas de rayon
de soleil à l'horizon mais des
températures stables avec des minimales
à 7°gr des maximales à 12°gr dans le
département dimanche on prend les mêmes
et on recommence des conditions météo et
des températures très similaires il fera
de 7 à 12° tout de suite les invités du
le tremplin des voix saison 9 arrive
bientôt à son terme la finale du
concours de champ national porté par
l'association la voix en scène se tient
ce samedi à partir de 19h à la Maison de
l'Environnement de manilé Hamo 20
finalistes seront répartis dans trois
catégories justement deux d'entre eux
sont avec nous sur ce plateau ayolune
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes-vous une
artiste en catégorie donc en lise dans
la catégorie auteur compositeur Inter
prête tout comme dioxine qui était qui
est à vos côté bonsoir salut bonsoir
voilà vous êtes tous les deux dans dans
cette catégorie justement on va
commencer avec vous comment vous vous
sentez à de jours de de cette finale
super bien en soit très excité de de ce
qui va se passer ça va être un bel
événement donc j'ai hâte dixine bon bah
c'est tout pareil juste un peu de stress
moi quand même je t'avoue c'est un peu
compliqué mais on gère le stress et de
toute façon on est là pour passer un
super bon moment ensemble avec les
invités avec tout le monde ça va être ça
va être génial on va faire votre
connaissance dans un instant alors en
face de vous on l'accueille quasiment
tous les ans sur ce plateau c'est audre
brouant bonsoir bonsoir organisatrice de
ce trempelin des voies alors même
question quel est votre état d'esprit là
on est dans la dernière ligne droite de
cette saison 9 bah un peu de rush quand
même même si avec le temps on est un peu
habitué mais un petit peu de rush donc
que tout se passe bien dès demain parce
que demain ils sont déjà en répète alors
quelques chiffres de cette 9e saison
plus de 400 candidatures au départ 160
artistes ont été auditionnés sur trois
auditions comment vous avez trouvé le le
cru de cette édition de cette 9e saison
impressionnant déjà d'être passé du
simple au double je crois qu'on était à
250 à peu près l'année dernière on
arrive à on approche des 500 cette année
et et du coup le niveau est tellement
élevé que c'était très difficile pour
nous que ce soit comité d'écoute et à
toutes les étapes le jury je pense que
ils ont bien
transpiré ils seront 20 sur scène du
coup pour pour la finale on l'a dit dans
trois catégories
il y aura des propositions artistiques
différentes pour le pour le public oui
en fait on essaie vraiment de de de
choisir avec eux des titres qui leur
correspond aussi c'est un spectacle donc
c'est en live avec les musiciens donc on
essaie de voir aussi des chansons qui
bouge un peu pour proposer vraiment des
choses intéressantes on va faire la
connaissance justement de des artistes
qui seront sur scène samedi alors a
yolune vous venez de lesson Savini sur
Orge vous avez 24 ans la musique est une
passion pour vous depuis votre 13 ans
mais ça fait à peu près 3 ans que vous
vous enregistrez quel est votre style
pour ceux qui qui nont encore pas
entendu ayolun je dirais de la pop
alternative j'ai beaucoup d'influence
notamment rock soul un peu de jazz aussi
parfois du coup je mélange un peu ça à
ma sauce et ça donne un côté un peu
Grune et pop alors pour se faire une
idée on va écouter un extrait de votre
prestation en
demi-finale je veux pas un
empé ton cœur est
bétéembrasse que
mignon délicat comme de la so un peu
brincié serais-tu en fait un
souverainébé je lire dans tes yeux comme
tu as envie de mes bras autour de
toi pourentendre davantage faudra venir
samedi pour pour pour la finale bah
pourquoi participer à à ce tremplin des
voix qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré dans ce
concours j'avais envie de me challenger
de rencontrer d'autres artistes de
rencontrer des coachs aussi de voir un
peu avec le public ce que ce que mon
univers pouvait donner parce que c'est
que très récemment que j'ai changer da
et j'ai commencé à chanter en français
et du coup je sais pas j'avais envie de
de voilà de Me challenger de montrer un
peu sortir de ma chambre alors dans
votre catégorie samedi il y aura en face
de vous notamment dioxine alors vous
êtes originaire de la Réunion mais c'est
dans les ivelines que vous passé
l'essentiel de votre jeunesse dans le
quartier du valiou à plaisir vous
comptez-vous plusieurs années
d'expérience dans la musique au sein du
groupe ras retour aux sources et vous
êtes revenu sur scène après 10 ans de de
pause bah pareil pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas qui êtes vous ben moi je
suis un rappeur de base de formation
après je me suis tourné un peu vers le
champ et cetera et c'est vrai que j'ai
grandi et j'ai fait mes classes à
plaisir dans le quartier du valébou avec
mes mes compères aussi et et après j'ai
mré vers la Réunion et de la Réunion ben
j'ai commencé là réellement à travailler
ma musique sortir un album faire des
tournées faire plein plein de choses
très intéressantes après la vie de
famille a fait que je me suis mis un peu
derrière mais je vis encore toujours de
la musique he je suis d je travaille
avec plein plein de je de l'île de la
Réunion et après je me suis challengé je
me suis dit allez c'est parti aussi je
vais je vais me lancer un petit défi
pour mes enfants j'adore voir les yeux
de mes enfants briller donc je dis c'est
parti don pareil pour se faire une idée
on va écouter un extrait de votre
demi-finale yes je parle avec mes
souvenirs coincés dans mon
quotidien j'entrevois le futur qui
m'attire et me dit viens traverser t
d'épreuves sans comprendre le sens ce
que la vie m'a appris je l'ai pris et
compris fleurter avec ma
[Musique]
chance même si tout s'effondre je ne
dois pas renoncer pas renoncer je crois
en moi je suis prêt à avancer on m'a dit
vi
vi dans ce monde la même question que
pour aolune alors vous avez parlé de
challenge c'est c'est ça qui vous a
attiré dans dans ce tremplin bah oui un
moment j'étais en fait j'ai j'ai repris
la musique au bout de 10 ans et j'avais
vraiment envie cette C cette envie de me
lancer des défis de sortir des nouveaux
titres essayer de me challenger comme
elle comme disait aolun aussi mais et je
pense aussi je l'ai fait beaucoup pour
mes enfants voilà comme je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure j'adore voir mes les yeux de
mes enfants briller et j'ai envie d'ussi
leur montrer que que un rêve est il faut
il faut il faut aussi croire en ses
rêves et je pense que je suis l'exemple
et on est les miroirs pour les enfants
aussi donc que ouais je fais beaucoup
pour mes enfants on le disait
différentes propositions musicales il y
a aussi différents parcours de vie
parcours artistiques aussi qui sont
représentés dans ce trempelin exactement
puisque comme il y a plusieurs
catégories on a cette année des petits
qui ont 9 ans
euh donc qui démarre il y en a pour qui
c'est la première scène et on a
effectivement des artistes émergents qui
ont déjà un certain parcours et on
essaie vraiment de de de de de de les
accompagner à chacun à leur niveau de
développement en fait voilà avant la
finale ils ont été accompagnés par des
des coachs c'est ça oui à chaque étape
on les coach alors en collectif puis en
individuel et demain ils ont une grosse
grosse session de travail de coaching
scénique de coaching vocal et même de de
formation de formation sur sur le le
développement artistique pour que tout
soit prêt pour samedi alors avez parlé
des trois catégories il y a auteur
compositeur interprète il y a la
catégorie moins de 18 ans et plus de 18
ans c'est bien ça c'est ça pour pour ce
tremplin alors comment va se dérouler la
la soirée pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas le principe on le connaît bien ici à
tv78 mais comment ça va se dérouler euh
alors du coup ça commence à 19h déjà le
public peut voter du coup il y a deux
prix Prix du Public prix du jury le
public pourra voter comme le jury donc
voilà ce sera en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux sur Youtube et bah du coup ce
sera parti pour parce que ce qui est
bien si on ne peut pas venir sur place
on peut suivre la soirée à distance sur
la page Youtube de la voix en scène et
on peut voter aussi à distance he c'est
bien ça on peut voter également à
distance alors deux prix seront remis
vous avez dit Prix du Jury prix du
public le jury pour en parler cette
année est-ce que c'est popr les mêmes
personnes qui le composent chaque année
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres d'autres
éléments cette année dans le dans le
jury en partie c'est des figures du du
du secteur du 78 qui représente un peu
différentes catégories du du milieu
professionnel et puis chacée on a des
nouveaux qui rejoignent les anciens on
va dire et que remporte-t-il qu'est-ce
qu'il y a la clé justement de du
trempelin alors bah il y a des cadeaux
de de nos partenaires donc des du
matériel du coaching de l'accompagnement
parce que c'est quand même notre point
fort euh de l'enregistrement
studio voilà déjà aviricro et tout ça
c'est V super ch et on va terminer avec
un petit tour de table avec vous bah
justement qui est une vie victoire ou
pas samedi quelle est la suite pour vous
aolune moi là actuellement je suis en
train de préparer un EP qui sortira en
2024 dans le courant de l'année donc
donc voilà et j'ai un single aussi pour
fin février et pour vous y ben moi
pareil aussi je travaille sur un projet
là qui sortirait cette année fin d'année
et après beaucoup de scènes sur la
Réunion et encore quelques scènes sur la
métropole aussi en 2024 bon courage à
vous à tous les finalistes de ce
tremplin des voies une toute dernière
question pratique est-ce qu'il faut
réserver à l'avance on peut prendre son
billet directement sur place samedi si
on veut venir voir ses prestations c'est
toujours mieux de réserver en avance
pour ne pas avoir de surprise comme
l'année dernière on a dû refuser du
monde à un moment donné mais pour
l'instant vous pouvez encore venir merci
à tous les trois d'être venu en parler
on le rappelle même si on vient pas sur
place on peut suivre la soirée à
distance vous voyez la page Facebook de
la voix en scène s'afficher sinon pour
venir sur place c'est donc samedi hein
cette finale du trempelin des voies
saison 9 à partir de 19h à la Maison de
l'Environnement de manie Lamo et donc
vous avez toutes les informations sur le
site trempelindesvoix.com qui s'affiche
sur votre écran voilà c'est la fin du 78
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dès lundi pour une nouvelle édition et
d'ici là passer un excellent weekend sur
[Musique]
tv78